uh
kevin what was what what uh was your
tipping point where you got into
the hole and you were depressed and you
know and in that state of mind are you
feeling helpless are you feeling like
there's no way in the world i can get
out maybe you help us
understand since you're saying if you've
never been in it you will know about it
what was your experience like
it is when you find that you just don't
want to do anything
you used to maybe you like to go fishing
a lot or maybe you're into hot rods
whatever it is and you're not finding
joy in those things that you used to
find joy in
go to the doctor find out what's going
on i went to my regular physician
and i told him i go doc i think stuff is
passing me by here i'm just not
feeling like like i used to you know a
long time ago
so he had me take this test and it's
called the phq-9
patient health questionnaire nine and
many many places use this
and it's it's a test just nine questions
and you take this
to see if you may have depression
so i took this test that it only takes a
couple of minutes
he walked in the room with this he's
holding this and he goes kevin
you have depression how do you feel
about this and mind you i've had heart
issues i got three stents in my heart we
talked about the cancer
i've had some brain injuries and then a
divorce and
and all the other stuff so i'm thinking
depression on top of all this
but that's when we talked about some
medications and some different avenues
of approach
so that's a start and it's okay well
let's let's work on this
put yourself on top for a while i'm
looking at the questions right now i
found the phq-9 test
on mdcalc.com first one is
little interest or pleasure in doing
things not at all several days
more than half two days nearly every
days second question feeling down
depressed or hopeless not at all several
days same same thing again
number three trouble falling or staying
asleep or sleeping too much
feeling tired or having little energy
poor appetite or overeating
feeling bad about yourself or that you
are a failure
or have let yourself or your family down
trouble concentrating on things such as
reading the newspaper or watching
television
moving or speaking so slowly that other
people could have noticed
or so fidgety or restless that you have
been moving a lot
more than usual last but not least
thoughts that you have
you would be better off dead or thoughts
of hurting yourself
in some way interesting list of
questions so those nine
gives a doctor an idea whether you're
depressed or not
it can truly help yes how are you doing
so just those nine questions you know i
highly recommend that to folks to see
how are you doing
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye